mac os or a windows based laptop that is
the question that has always been on the
forefront of any media student video
editor photographer graphics designer
and practically almost anyone who has
been or still is in the creative
industry
most creatives have signed their souls
to the apple way of life and often have
decided swear off windows for good
like
creators like myself
but hey
having been raised on microsoft
operating systems i'm willing to give
this baby a chance
as a writer designer and video creative
myself
a laptop that maximizes productivity and
is easy to bring on the go at any given
time is a huge plus
and usually the decision lies between
choosing something that packs powerful
hardware versus something that is
extremely mobile and portable
that being said this takes the cake for
anyone looking for a windows based
macbook pro
hey guys it's abita here from geek
culture and this is the huawei mate book
x pro 2020 the huawei mate book x pro
first launched in 2018 and has won many
awards and accolades for its surprising
power precision and overall quality
suited for professionals and those in
creative lines of work
looking at the 2020 version nothing has
changed aesthetically the matebook x
it still looks like it's preceding
additions but it's more of a hardware
spec bump by no means is this
necessarily a bad thing as the saying
goes if it ain't broke don't fix it and
that is the ethos of what the matebook x
pro 2020 is trying to do
starting with the overall design and
build the macbook x pro is a good
looking and clean laptop it comes in a
gorgeous space gray aluminum chassis
along with sleek curved beveled edges on
the sides a well-positioned full-size
keyboard a large click pad and even a
fingerprint sensor that doubles as a
power on button
in terms of input and output a usba 3.0
we have the usual headphone jack and a
pair of usbcs that support all
thunderbolt 3 features
it also boasts a quad speaker system
firing through grilles on the side of
the keyboard and some cutouts in the
bottom panel these speakers are loud and
provide good sound all these come
packaged in a very compact 14.6
millimeters or just short of 5 8 of an
inch thick
and weighing approximately 1.33
kilograms or under three pounds making
this ultrabook one that is portable and
comfortable to take anywhere
in fact those in particular believe how
this passed the one-handed opening test
what brings the whole thing together is
its stunning 13.9 inch nearly bezel-less
display a whopping 91 screen to body
ratio
this 3000 by 2000 resolution
260 pixel per inch display offers a
different aspect ratio of 3x2 than a
conventional 16x9 widescreen aspect
ratio we see in conventional laptops
this gives much better productivity due
to more real estate whether it's typing
out a document or working on a design
the hundred percent srgb white color
gamut also makes images and videos more
vibrant and the details more vivid
which is perfect for creatives in terms
of color accuracy
better yet the display itself is touch
screen with gesture control that allows
you to scroll
zoom select and even swipe down with
three fingers to capture the screen
effortlessly if you're not the type to
smudge your screen the large click pad
provides excellent precision and click
feel the white backlit keyboard also
gives satisfaction with a combination of
1.2 millimeters travel and a subtle soft
click once fully depressed another thing
to note is that the keyboard is splash
proof which is a very good plus
one feature that took us by surprise is
the webcam on the laptop hidden
underneath a key in the function button
row
it is a nifty and smart design to avoid
adding more space on the screen it's a
clever way of hiding the camera and you
can simply store it away when you don't
want to be seen guess that means no one
sticking tape over the camera and
further ruining the quality of your
webcam big plus there
[Music]
however the camera's position makes it
an unflattering angle for some and when
it comes to zoom calls
you can forget typing while on call as
your knuckles will get in the way
it's also not the best front camera you
would have
sporting only one megapixel
don't expect crisp images or videos
unless you're creative who depends on
good webcam like a vlogger or a cam girl
for example
the webcam gets the job done
the microphone sensitivity is
decent in fact
relying up fall microphones to
accurately pick up sound and small feet
away
with all these features and the hardware
this baby packs some pretty awesome
performance specs for an ultrabook
the latest 10th gen intel i7 processor
nvidia geforce mx250
16 gigabytes
lpddr3 ram
one terabyte ssd
all these specs make this the everyday
machine powerful enough to bear the
grunt work like photoshop 1080p video
editing on premiere pro and even casual
gaming
which few ultrabooks can do with ease
all other productivity tasks will run
here with no hiccups
running on windows 10 home edition the
matebook x pro does not come with
bloatware with only proprietary huawei
ads like huawei share and huawei pc
manager
just like apple has its eyedrop huawei
hasn't emerged with its own
the huawei share app allows huawei phone
users to utilize high speed direct file
and data transfer with a simple tab with
its dedicated nfc zone and simply drag
and drop with a touchscreen has made the
task a lot more convenient
not only that the huawei share app can
also be used as a multi-screen
collaboration conveniently popping up a
mirrored cast of your phone onto your
laptop allowing you to put your phone
down and multitask all within the laptop
itself
next comes the huge 56 watt hour battery
boasting up to 13 hours of video
playback 11 hours of web browsing and 15
hours of light to moderate work
all in a single charge
plenty of battery for a busy work day or
even a long flight and if 13 hours is
not good enough
the 65 watt usb c charging provides
blazing fast charging at a full hundred
percent for an average of 90 minutes
while inactive
the key takeaway is the lack of a power
brick like many conventional laptops
have
another great convenience in terms of
portability and space
if you're looking for further expansion
say
hooking it up to an external monitor the
matebook x pro comes bundled with a
matebook dock 2.0 right of the box
on top of that you can also buy some
accompanying accessories like the huawei
bluetooth mouse swift and the huawei
backpack swift
isn't really that great some of you
might be thinking to yourselves well
yeah there are a few downsides if you
want me to be nitpicky about it for a
laptop that's targeted for creatives
there's no sd card slot which is just a
bummer to say the least
the lack of hardware customization
options is also a factor that might
potentially put off those interested in
the matebook x pro
especially with only one terabyte of
storage space it might not last very
long if you want a laptop that has
macbook performance a laptop running a
windows 10 with support portability
this
is definitely a heavy hitter the huawei
mate book x pro is out in singapore and
it's priced at two thousand six hundred
and ninety eight dollars
[Music]